It's interesting that you
combine those things though,
that you have this a gym or there's all
this martial arts stuff and then the
tactical stuff.
What do you do to chill out?
Because it seems like everything
is fucking Coco, coco cow.
Everything is lifting weights,
shooting and pull on ropes,
shooting and arm dragging and shooting.
Um, what do you do to calm yourself?
I am hobby heavy. Hobby heavy. Well you
show me your drawing. Very talented.
So I draw, I burped. I
bird watch. Birdwatch Yup.
I bet a birdwatcher since I
was 10 years old, really? Golf.
I go down this list, guitar, drums, um,
Cook. Let me see here. I got so many
freaking hobbies. It's ridiculous. And,
but the good thing about most
of ms I could go to and um,
and um, it doesn't take me a lot
of time or energy to invest in it.
A fishing on big time fisherman,
outdoorsman, woodsmen type of thing.
I love that stuff.
I get into the rocky mountains at least
once a year and two like privation
training here just on my own.
So like what do you do when you do that?
This camp out there and live off the
land. You try it, try it, try to sustain,
you know, with what I have and
what's available to me. And it also,
uh, and it also includes a
orienteering so you know what,
over 24,000 scale
topographical map and um,
so orienteering and,
and these are wilderness areas,
not like national parks or forests. And
then, uh, tried to let it kill it, eat it,
you know, along the way. Carry,
I carry enough food so I'm not going to
be miserable so I'm not going to suffer.
How many days do you do when
you're out there? Well, it, it, it,
now that I'm retired not
before to five anymore.
You're like bringing a ruck
sack or something like that.
Yup. So I pack in, Yup.
Whatever. A, whenever I need. And
you know, pat king a ruck is a,
it's a real, it's artwork man. Sure.
Even if you've been in the
military forever, you know,
you just never ever get that
down to a perfect science,
especially a weight. Yeah. Cause you got,
wait, you're going to rain, you got, uh,
you know, the, the uh, uh,
the situation may dictate
to strip this and add that.
And then where are you going to put it
and you bring satellite phone or anything?
We do it or you do I uh, I bring it, yeah,
I bring one of those cause Saturn's, yep.
You don't want to roll an ankle out there.
Well plus I usually go to Montana,
like the Bob Marshall, so that's both
the highest concentration of grizzlies.
Lower 48. So you're not on the
top of the food chain management.
Big Hungary's out there. So that's
a fucking scary spot. Well it's,
it's always usually pretty good
unless you run into a female. Yeah.
With their clubs. That's when it
gets super sketchy. I just wrote,
I just wrote about that.
Um, that's not, I write,
so I write for a ballistic magazine
and combat handguns and I just wrote an
article about that wouldn't ballistic,
uh,
about what should be in your
personal survival kit. You know,
let's say you go on a day fishing
trip in Alaska. What should,
what do you have in that thing?
You know,
in the event that you need to go
into contingency planning mode,
that shit hits the fan. You got to have
something on you instead of just your,
your Orvis fly rod and
a couple of beat heads.
Yet the big debate with a hunter's is
should you bring bear spray or feed you
bring a pistol.
Yup.
Especially both smart that I need to
anytime bear country, I bring both.
I got them both on and I've talked to a
lot of gristle hunters and I put that in
that article too. It's like guys, you
know, I've done some research here.
Uh, but yeah, so I'll
bring, I'll bring both.
Have you had any
encounters when you're out?
I've had almost every year
really the closest one,
15 yards. Maybe that was the
first time ever up there too.
And I'm smoked. I'm at the
end. This is what I was doing.
I started doing these when we were,
when I was active,
so bringing up unit guys and
this one was 95 miles long.
We walked from um,
uh,
a little spot on the map. Oh, Columbia
falls south of Columbia Falls,
Montana to Lincoln, the home Ted
Kaczynski. The Unabomber. Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So walk this stretch and it's 95
miles right in north to south,
and you've got to cross like three
different mountain passes and smoker.
So the s I think it was,
it was the fifth day. Yeah.
Because we had one more Ron,
one more rest overnight.
And on the fifth day I had a,
we would walk like lines of drift
and stuff like that, you know? Uh,
and whenever I couldn't see 25 yards
up ahead of me, I would, you know,
clap my hands, make some
racket coming through mark,
you know, that kind of thing.
Because grids want nothing to do with you,
right.
You get in between their young,
their food source or you startle him.
That's when you run into trouble. Right.
So I did not want to stay, and here I
am, I'm, and I've got six guys, Whitney,
but they're lagging behind.
Uh, and I, you know,
coming through and I look up ahead and
this gigantic male stands up and the only
thing that I could,
my only reaction was whoa.
I mean I was just blown away.
15 yards is less distance
than you flew when you crash.
Right.
And flew in the air,
you have to fly in the air and it passed
that five yard. That's right. Yup.
Wow. Yup. He took off. Boom.
He was gone. Lucky. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because I mean that's a lot.
That's a lot of animal.
Yeah.
I tell you when you're standing
like in the woods in the wild,
50 yards, 1550 yards, and
when that thanks stood up,
that's all I could say. That's all. I
mean, I had a gun and bear spray on me.
I went for neither of them
all I can think it was. Whoa.
And then when he took off, my next
thought was, where's my camera? Oh, Jesus.
Well that's nature's cleanup crew right
there. Anything that limps falls down,
fucks up. Yep. That's what it's there for.
That's why there's a thousand pounds
of him, man. He needs to keep eating.
Yeah. It's a, it's a majestic
animal. You see one in the
wild. You, you realize like,
wow, like this is just
nature has a system. Yup.
They know what they're doing when
they want to get rid of a moose.
They sent one of these motherfuckers
in there. Yeah. I mean really.
So when you're doing these,
um,
these things that you keeping
a journal when you do in these,
these trips where you by herself?
Um,
and I usually don't go by myself.
I usually have straphangers and
they're different every year.
It's a lot of times it's just like this,
you know, a couple of guys talking,
saying, Oh man, I like
to do that with you. Oh,
we're just send me an email and
I'll send you the dates. Oh Wow.
Because one is securities and numbers,
right. Especially at Greer's country.
Plus I like teaching stuff.
So I'll have guys who I could teach like
orienteering and you know, field craft,
you know, making a fire with sticks
and kind of that kind of thing. And uh,
the right way to, uh, maybe to
prep and cook a trout. You know,
uh, so do you bring a rod with
you? Yeah. Oh yeah. Yeah, yeah.
I'm one of them small breakdown.
I, I'll, I'll bring two of them.
I'll bring a,
tell us telescoping a 10 cholera and a,
a four piece, like a
five weight Orvis. Okay.
Because it's fly rod
then. Yeah. Okay. I am,
for me that's sustenance because
I'm not taking a lot of food.
Plus I want to fish. I want it to
be time off and I want to chill.
I don't want to just work my
ass off when I'm on these.
So I'm out there ripping lips,
but I'm eating two of them in
the morning and two at night. Uh,
and then it's a lot.
It's a lot of fun.
I've been doing these things now
since 98 I think that's a great way to
decompress too. Yeah. The places I go to,
one of them is I will lose cell coat,
cell phone coverage an hour before
I hit the end of the dirt road.
Yup. So, and then you stopped the
color, you were at the end of the road.
Now you're, you know, you're already in,
you're just at the edge of the Wilderness
area deep into a national forest and
then into the wilderness for
however many days, miles.
Uh, we run another folks in. You're out
there very rarely the best. You know,
I loved walking like on the
95 mile one and seeing nobody,
nobody,
I mean these places that are remote,
the Frank Church and Idaho,
uh,
I walked wind river and
uh, Wyoming, they, uh,
the Frank Church, I walked from
the town of Salmon to McCall.
That one smoked me.
How far is that?
They did w w on a scale of things as
a crow flies. I, it's not that far.
I think it's 60 miles or something, but
it's straight up, straight down down.
It's the most horrific and
d just terrifying terrain.
I mean, especially if
you're, you know, uh,
if your objective is to move from point
a to point B and not just an out and
back, let me see how far it can go. No.
When you got somebody picking you up at
point B and you have to be there. Oh man,
it is a freaking smoker. Yeah. I've
never been in the Frank Church, but um,
my friend Ryan Callahan was living up
there for a long time and it's cool.
He says it's amazing up there.
It's also so it's so remote,
but yet it's so close to Boise.
Yeah, that far, right? Yeah. Right.
Yeah. The grand scale themes,
things, it's not, it's not
that far. Right. But there's,
when you have these wilderness
areas, like uh, I don't know,
let's say it's 500 million square
acres or whatever it is. You know,
that's also a colposcope by
national parks and stuff.
And you know,
national parks will have dirt roads and
I mean they'll have little scatterings
of, of population here and there,
but those wilderness areas,
there's nothing in those.
Just animals.
There's no dirt roads and it's
such a complete ecosystem to me.
You have to have everything from wolves,
the grizzlies to mule deer to elk.
It's all living up in there.
Yeah. Yeah, they are cool.
I mean, I love doing those two because
you have to thank, there isn't,
there is an element of danger here that,
that can kill me.
And it's not just a big hungry,
you could get cut and show out there
because nobody's coming to get you.
Even if you got that beacon, you
know, forest service and stuff,
they're probably busy servicing,
you know,
grandma broke her leg trying to take a
picture of a bison in this national park
coming into that national,
that wilderness area, you know,
there was no h LZs there and
stuff like that. Right? So man,
I love that, that element of danger,
especially since I retired. You know,
I want to be cold, tired, hungry,
and maybe a little scared. Um,
and I want that several times
a year because, uh, yeah,
it's, you know, it's primal,
right?
And I think most guys need that.